[Applause]
they're calling for president Dana
balawatte to resign she came to power
last month after former president Pedro
Castillo was arrested and jailed after
trying to dissolve Congress Mariana
Sanchez reports from the capital Lima
[Music]
her home and five children behind in
puno to march in Lima she says she's
never felt more offended by a Peruvian
president
fueling anger among these Southern
citizens
we feel outraged what does she think
that we're bolivians we're legitimate
peruvians and we're marching here every
day and she has trampled our rights
a day after the government sent hundreds
of soldiers to occupy puno and extended
a curfew Amalia says such measures are
fueling people's anger
at least 18 people were killed in puno
two weeks ago in the worst day of
political unrest
I want Justice for our brothers who have
died Dina has to pay for what they have
done to us we're not animals for the
police to kill us in that way we just
came to March peacefully without weapons
nearly 60 people have been killed many
after Security Forces opened fire on
demonstrators
on Wednesday boluarte told the
organization of American states that her
government respects the rule of law and
security forces must protect all
citizens OAS members backed boluarte
although the presidents of Mexico and
Colombia have said she's not the
country's legitimate leader any analysts
say there is still room for the violence
to escalate they say it may take
International pressure to prevent the
government from ultimately imposing
authoritarian rule many analysts are not
optimistic there is a way out of the
crisis in the near future
the worst case scenario is the most
likely scenario that boluarte stays her
cabinet gets even tougher no agreement
is reached in Parliament and the
elections are either kicked to 2024 are
not done for a long time which will
generate a radicalization of the
protests boluarte has asked for peace
and debate Amalia says it's too late
as a mother it hurts to see how many of
our children have died we no longer want
a truce or dialogue we are hurt with so
many dead we will fight as far as we can
until the end
many peruvians feel the same way Lima